hey we're the fab five from netflix's
clear eye and we're doing the wired
autocomplete interview
[Music]
and we're doing the wired otter compute
oh
my god i got it
how queer eye was
cast um we all uh
auditioned it was come on do bobby's
hunger games
yeah i was like it's kind of like
american idol meets hunger games
they put us all in a room together we
fought it out and
we won queer eye how does it work
beats us honey that is a loaded question
a little wild wild
westish in terms of production we kind
of figure it out as we go
um after the first day of discovery
where we meet our respective heroes
we all sort of get together with our
lovely executive producers
and also our story producers for each uh
for each episode and we just kind of
hash it out and we figure it out
how old are the queer eye guy 35
35 37 31
30 8
how do the queer eye
guys know each other not very well
from a tv show from when we were cast
which has been two years now so we've
known each other for two years wow how
much does
queer eye spend on each person talking
about money is tacky yeah
even we don't know that answer yeah yeah
does queer eye pay for everything yeah
yeah we don't make our heroes pay for
that yeah they get everything for free
dude queer i keep the furniture
yeah they do i would never give people
can you imagine
if we took it over if tom jackson got
back right there
if tom jackson got back that armchair
yes
yeah we do yeah we can clear our kiki
all the time
um he's having a good time to laugh do
queer eye guys get along
uh no no cannot stand no depends on the
day
do we're i keep in touch
not at all with our heroes yes yes and
each other
but also honest to god we really do get
along the only thing that we ever really
will come to blows over is temperature
temperature
this hoe likes it way too cold yeah
without a jacket
that's not untrue how to pronounce tan
france oh my gosh
actually this is perfectly appropriate
because i joined anthony on a show a
couple of nights ago where andy cohen
kept pronouncing it tarn
just say the letters t-a-n yeah i think
people assume that because i have an
accident that they shouldn't
yeah they should time your time hello
yeah but you don't have to sit in my
accent please just say it in your accent
yes it's just hand
yeah is tan france naturally gray
actually let me field this question it
would be impossible for him to have salt
and pepper
bleach and tone that well there's no way
you can artificially make something
that perfect and also it wouldn't be
possible to dye my
beard and maintain how short my hair is
it would be i'm just going to pull the
next one off because it ties into it
yeah
how to get tan france hairline
this is all placement for all our
personal endeavors i love where this is
going
tan france
[Laughter]
from queer eye fam he is from
dan cav don don cassio i have told you
so many dances
south yorkshire england all right you
know me
next anthony perovski who does
anthony perovski look like john mayer
oh my god mayor franco i get christian
bale a lot
i think we have the same mouth does
anthony from
we're i have a partner
yes next question boom
you need help baby noah does
anthony from queer i
have a brother brother
they're gonna say brother
can i just tell you this summer when we
were in kansas he was doing the cookbook
and i was just so proud
because they're like some really amazing
i got to eat so many
meals over the summer what does anthony
barofsky
do for uh living he's keeping me
safe usually um it doesn't pay that well
i'm hoping that he's gonna get raised
someday
he is a celebte
what his future occupation is going to
be can i tell them anthony is going to
win the academy award
trust and believe for best supporting
actor he is the most amazing actor
you're talking about go looking at old
youtube clips of me
look at his old youtube acting clips
this is like honestly
the nicest final question
what is it this one time oh my god
anthony and i were on
a photo shoot and he told me that he had
something really important to tell me
and the look on his face i thought he
was going to tell me that he was in love
with me
and so before he told me that i said
honey i think we're much better friends
i just i think that we're such good
friends and this was my face
yeah i couldn't believe it no i'm sorry
wait let's replicate a face
yes that's the face i will i won't say
what i said next
but here's the question for jonathan is
he from queer eye
oh oh really cute it's really cute
i think the reason they asked is because
you and you
both insist on holding my hand in an
interlaced fashion
you need to not write checks that you
cannot cash i am willing to cut those
checks
i'm so sick of all of you guys you know
with your beautiful bodies threatening
to lay with me with your tops off and it
never happens
throw it bobby burke
where did bobby burke go
to college bobby burke is a true
american success story because
he with literally a sixth grade
education
17 cents in his pocket
he went to jefferson city he said you
know what i'm going to redo this capital
and then i moved to new york today yeah
i didn't graduate high school
there we go but did you have a ge day um
no no i didn't i
were bobber why didn't you graduate high
school uh because i left home at 15 and
i
didn't have oh my god i have a really
good idea that could honest to god like
probably get you like 17 houses and it
could make all of us like
scripted writers we reboot
the one where adam sandler goes back to
school and you could go back to school
we could get your high school diploma
remember like happy guild or no happy
madison
billy madison let's remain billy madison
what band was bobby burke in
it was called his voice his boys as a
christian
his voice boys with a capital h
as in jesus that guy of champion wow
because
he he worked through us yeah and when we
sang
it was channeling jesus oh yeah
where did bobby burke grow up missouri
missouri little baby town in missouri
where does bobby burke
live wait i have the alley somebody put
his address
he's in los angeles l.a is bobby burke
as gorgeous in real life as he is on
burke tv yes i am adopted
gorgeous dude bobby burke that's all you
need to know
jonathan van ness how much does
each other's haircuts
consultation you know what i mean it
depends on how much of a payment of nash
you're going to be
how much would you so you would charge
me 10. yeah
okay wait i actually am free well
i'm a nice person
and he will make you pay for it later
what happened
what happened to jonathan honestly it's
a good question
yeah no honestly it's a vile queen
i asked myself that oh it's like
whatever happened to baby jane whatever
happened to baby john i get it
it's a lot what happened to him
what's not happening i'm gay i'm angry
i'm on my way to my style cow it's not
quite happening yet it's not clicking i
want it to click
booked him busy welcome jbn what's next
is jonathan van ness single yes
and it's so great it's so ready to be
going
jonathan vanessa's birthday my
birthday's on march 28th which is also
miss
gaga's birthday and also my mummy's is
the day after
oh she was very pissed off yeah i was
like she
had a birthday again i was three weeks
late and she was like if you're this
late why don't you stay one more day we
can share a birthday
and then oh what else thank you i know
three of us have a birthday within a
month of each really cute
does jonathan van ness have siblings yes
he does
the youngest of four we have all the
young men yeah
that is really cute youngest of three
jonathan youngest of four bobby youngest
of
two two anthony is the youngest i'm the
youngest
of three yeah tan is the youngest of 37
yeah
there are a lot of kids in cashmere
craba brown it's gorgeous
who is
can i tell you all something when i was
leaving um social work
in psychotherapy i did this video to get
like the attention of agents
in my friend's garage where i was like
who is caramel brown
i don't know how to take it down you
know if i record it and it won't go down
oh my god you've got to test
one of a few youtube videos that you
definitely want to google everyone's
like if you want an agent you have to
like tell people who you are
and i was like well how do you do that
and they were like oh yeah they were
like
wait wait what was your answer he's
fashionable
i'm fashioned now i'm talking i don't
know in leah
oh that previous one who is caramel
brown partner
oh it's my baby daddy his name is ian
when you say baby daddy it sounds like
ian birthed your children
i actually started calling my baby daddy
because i i feel that it was so
uncomfortable for me as a gay man
calling another man who i'm in a
long-term relationship with my boyfriend
at our age so i call him my baby daddy
because i hate the fact i mean now we
have we're engaged we're gonna get
married but we gotta remember seven
years ago this was not an option but i
like that too because baby daddy
like you guys are in the trenches of
this parenthood thing raising these
children together
what does caramel brown do what does he
not do
thank you is a culture expert ex-social
worker he is a
father he is a partner he is a damn
oh yes he is a lover of a global
ambassador
unofficially of coca-cola
i do like a lot of colors and a lover of
all things pizza
anthony good job
[Applause]
christian so i have a 22 and 19 year old
where did caramel brown go to high
school
i went to parkland marjory stoneman
douglas where it's unfortunately famous
now for the mass shooting that happened
on february 14th
but what i do love is that that school
turned me into an activist and it has
turned all these young people to an
activist
and comprehensive gun legislation is
happening because
this generation is saying enough is
enough and they are going to make sure
that
no other child ever has to fear going
what did i say activist and
pre-politician
boom watch your head daddy
thank you so much for listening to our
banter hope
you learned some more stuff about us
that you did not know